hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's einen hund schritt denn
einige meiner zuschauer haben sich
kinder gewünscht
kaffee ist eine türkische wobei sich
keine türkische süßspeise es ist eine
orientalische süßspeise sondern die
dürfen nicht nur in der türkei die gibt
es auch in arabischen ländern
nein es gibt auch ein orientalisches
kann jeder aus dominiert er ist für mich
aus und ich glaube von av oder so reiste
mit oh und ah ist dann in den arabischen
ländern
jedenfalls ist ein warmes bisher ist
jedoch warm gegessen da benutzt man
nudeln nudeln fäden nein keine klassen
nudel fäden dafür dass wir dann im ofen
gebacken und da ist nur so eine
schichtkäse mit dabei und normalerweise
gibt es da einen bestimmten käse auch da
ist einfach geschmacksneutral und ohne
salz aber da wir den hier nicht haben
nehmen wir einfach mozzarella nutzer
laden lässt auch geschmacksneutral und
nach dem packen wird er dann noch
getränk mit etwas sogar so gut dass ich
ja ganz typisch für orientalische
spezialitäten jedenfalls zeige ich euch
einmal ganz kurz die zutaten für den
zuckersirup brauche ich ein fünf gläser
wasser 15 leser zucker und einem
spritzer zitronensaft und fürs kühle
versetzt brauche ich 250 gramm butter 2
esslöffel trauben sirup 500 gramm katar
jetzt sage ich noch etwas dazu und 440
gramm mozzarella
jetzt nehme ich zuerst einmal das wasser
und den zucker und zwar muss ich den
sirup erstellen und der muss dann später
auch kalt sein
deswegen den zuerst zu bereiten das
drama in einem topf eins zu eins dann
zucker mit rein und das ganze jetzt
aufkochen in den orientalischen
süßspeisen hauptserie zuckersirup
verwendet genau das ist was kommt
überall vor und immer mit rein immer von
morgens bis abends
und jetzt müssen wir ansetzen sich so
lange
das kochen bis sie das sogar aufgelöst
hat gezeigt ich möchte auch gleich für
meisten im löffel zum beispiel rührt und
dann den zuckersirup ein bisschen
fließen lässt
da merkt man das fließt nur nicht am
band und der zucker sirup ist dann
bereit wenn er am band fließt als wenn
es nicht mehr so tropft stoffe sieht man
jetzt ganz gut sind wie ein faden runter
geht sowieso erst einmal aufkochen
ich kann da schon mal die zwischenzeit
nutzen und die cut also die nudel fäden
zurechtschneiden und zwar jetzt beim
kaffee für unterschiede der morath hat
nämlich zuerst die falsche packungen
gekauft und weist dabei ekstase karriere
also frisch das sind dann diese
ungekochten und nicht gebackenen fäden
und dann gibt es nämlich noch das andere
das ist auch katars aber das ist
kabarett status also das ist schon das
fertige dessert was schon mit butter
vermengt ist und gebacken ist und da
kommt dann eben noch zuckersirup droge
solieren zuckers worten also das muss
man eigentlich schon noch packen und
dann den super sirup drauf geben
das ist aber ein anderes als
fertiggericht genau das ist schon fertig
und das ist jetzt sind es die hohen
schäden kann es sein dass immer genervt
ist nicht reinregnet nein
doch haben anscheinend es kommt mir so
vor ist wirst du wer ich bin nein du
willst du mir das jetzt aber nicht nicht
dass jetzt anfänglich das lied zu singen
also ja jedenfalls seht ihr jetzt die
karte fäden und schneidet sie klein ein
kleines stückchen
jetzt nehme ich die fäden und gibt es in
eine schüssel und jetzt müssen sie so
ein bisschen auseinander reißen das
nämlich so ein bisschen kompakt und ich
werde jetzt auflockern und da ich wollte
eigentlich immer gemacht zu ramadan zeit
zu festigen er ist total
ich liebte es auch und es ist diese
kombination ich gar nicht mag war war
dabei geht mal gar nicht
aber trotzdem probieren lassen wir uns
überraschen ja ich finde es richtig
lecker so kühner versteck dich gehört
fast meinen lieblings bisher aus der
orientalischen küche leichtfertig in
leipzig
dann natürlich auch den zero
kontrollieren er kocht jetzt wenn ich
hier schon kann man da noch mal mit dem
löffel rein und jetzt fließt es schon
fast wie an einem fragen ganz kleines
bisschen noch
jetzt ist der sirup soweit und ich kann
den herausstellen und auch ein spritzer
zitronensaft mit rein geben
jetzt muss ich den sirup vom herd
herunternehmen und richtig abkühlen
lassen also der muss später ganz kalt
sein
die taten sind jetzt vorbereitet und
jetzt nämlich die butter und den trauben
sirup und gebe es von der butter etwa
zwei esslöffel in den trauben sirup
betreiben und die restliche butter gebe
ich hier in einen topf und muss sie
verlassen soll jetzt nicht ganz heiß
werden sondern wirklich nur bei
mittlerer hitze schmelzen und in der
zeit kann ich nämlich schon mal den
trauben sehr hoch mit der butter
vermischen
und jetzt kommt die flüssige butter auch
die flädle wohl ich schon sagen auf die
kbf teig fäden flädle kernstücke der
sich mit click ist eine schwäbische
krieg ist und mir und jetzt wird es
alles mit den händen verknetet bis die
teig kneten komplett mit abpumpten was
nicht so schwierig ihr schweizer 500
gramm teig werden und 250 gramm butter
haben erzählt da nicht wissen wie viel
kalorien das ding ja ich auch deswegen
bitte rechnet ins nicht vor
aber das ist halt das gehört so und
deswegen macht man gefallen er freut
sich wie schon jeder ernährungsberatung
jedes fitnessstudio
die karte fäden vorbereitet jetzt muss
ich nur noch den mozzarella in dünne
scheiben schneiden
man denkt jetzt vielleicht es passt
absolut gar nicht dazu aber es passt
wirklich sehr gut dazu wenn man den
mozzarella weg lässt hat man im prinzip
eigentlich nur katastrophe also nur
dieses kaders gericht und kinder wird
eigentlich erst dann wenn mozzarella
oder hartkäse mit humorigen auch
mozzarella käse media access onkel für
käse des halt ohne salz und geschmacklos
und das sorgt für eine richtig tolle
konsistenz als man ist ja wahr wenn sie
mich dir vorstellen es kommt warm aus
dem ofen wird mit dem zero übergossen
und dann wenn man das so rein sticht
dann verläuft der käse noch so ein
bisschen sehr lecker also sind sehr sehr
komisches rezept immer gespannt das
stelle ich jetzt kurz zur seite und kann
jetzt bereits meine förmchen nehmen und
zwar gibt es normalerweise extra kniffe
teller die sind glaube ich sogar aus
aluminium also ganz dünne die habe ich
jetzt natürlich nicht ich nehme jetzt
hier diese gusseisen pfannen diesen auch
sehr hübsch aber man kann zum beispiel
auch eine große pfanne nehmen oder eine
große form so ein blech zum beispiel da
kann man auch eine große portion machen
aber ich finde sie kleinere portionen
wirklich das beste haus und haushalt
richtig hübsch aus wenn jeder gast sein
fähnchen bekommt und später wird es dann
auf seinem tablett serviert dann kommt
das ganze aus dem ofen
also ich finde die türkei gibt es immer
wenn man schon gerne zum restaurant
dann will die garnelen oder geliefert
werden da kann ja auch so ganz toll wenn
man sich seine eigene suppe macht zum
beispiel für immer machen hier über den
eisenbahn ist mir ganz wichtig dass die
eine antihaftbeschichtung haben die muss
man im ofen einmal vor brennen und dann
haben die diese beschichtung werden auch
schön schwarz
ich hab das jetzt noch nicht gemacht
aber ich muss sowieso die pfannen jetzt
mit dieser trauben sirup butter
bestreichen einmal für den geschmack und
einmal natürlich auch dass es nicht an
klebt das puccini ich jetzt erstmal
bestreiten ich fahre also sachen drin
trauben xerox rella käse
es wird laut
jetzt kommt eine erste schicht kbf in
die förmchen rein
die sollte den boden bedecken und je
nachdem wie groß die pfanne ist müsste
halt eben mehr oder weniger nehmen falls
jetzt eine große portion macher nehmt
ihr jetzt die hälfte und hälfte kommt
dann noch obendrauf
jetzt hier schön verteile
und dann noch ein bisschen flach drücken
jetzt kommt eine schicht mozzarella mit
raub und zwar schön flach und so dass
überall ein bisschen mozzarella ist
jetzt kommt noch mal die zweite schicht
kdf drauf und die muss man gleich
richtig fest gedrückt werden
und dann ist noch mal richtig fest
gedrückt wird nimm dir am besten ein
glas und drückt es nochmal schön platz
jetzt werden die desserts im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 220 grad für
etwa 20 minuten gebacken also bis die
oberfläche goldbraun ist und dann hole
ich sie ganz heißt raus und setzte
gleich weiterverarbeiten
frisch aus dem ofen
so muratow darf jetzt nämlich gleich
probieren habe ich frisch aus dem ofen
heraus und er ist wirklich aufpassen die
fans sind sehr heiß und am besten verrät
sie auch ganz heiß es könnte immer so
ein fähnchen nehmen und es hier auf
diese holzplatte sitzen da kann man die
nämlich so auch am tisch servieren
und jetzt kommt da der zucker sirup
drauf wie ich mal gespannt wie die stadt
könnt ihr jetzt übrigens selber
bestimmen wie viel zucker sirup ihr
haben möchte muss schon also wäre mir
jetzt noch keinen geschmack drin
außerdem buttergeschmack das solltet ihr
übrigens auch auf jeden fall mutter
nehmen und keine margarine da die butter
einfach viel besser schmeckt das kann
man zwischen eur vj ist ich mache
natürlich wenn man schon merklich zu
pizza genial das problem einmal aus und
jetzt da rein wo ich zu viel schlaf
ich finde das kann man sogar direkt am
tisch noch mal eine plattform wo das
sieht dann richtig cool los ist direkt
am tisch macht dann hat es sowas
freunde.de als gerade für alsfeld am
tisch nummer so was anbrennen
kurz einziehen lassen und dann könnt ihr
das essen aber ich glaubte was jetzt
noch ganz kurz vielleicht zwei drei
minuten
ich finde wir mal eine frau berichtet
die hose machen wir machen ja irgendwann
mit der gabel wirklich lecker dann hier
mit dem käse und diese ist diese maul
wärme wasser besonders doch nur die
karte was so liegt man mit dem bereich
gemacht
prominenteste schon der mozzarella und
jetzt könnt ihr das entweder so pur
essen oder ihr serviert zum beispiel
noch ein eis das so also dieses heiße
dass er unten karl nur einen lecker und
ich probiere es jetzt machen muss
und ich erzähle was dazu ihr könnt es
nämlich auch super vorbereiten und
entweder kurz vor dem verzehr dann
komplett backen oder ihr packt schon mal
vor und schiebt dann noch mal für fünf
minuten in den backofen damit der
mozzarella noch mal richtig heiß wird
und es schmeckt echt jetzt
er schmeckt es ja wirklich heiß und und
sehr heiß und käse und alan bisschen
blöd ist aber irgendwie also gebackenem
camembert genau so ähnlich menschen
schauten zu dieser flüsse geht heute ist
natürlich was ich weiß
käse oder nudeln und das ist so süß
wahnsinn und dann schmeckt ist so genial
wie gesagt da noch eine kugel eis dazu
als in der türkei ist man damals schon
dass er dazu das ist ein ganz spezielles
das muss ich auf jeden fall mal zeigen
und ja ich bin auch super lecker und vor
allem hat mir wirklich nicht viel
arbeitszeit kann's aber vorbereiten ganz
wenige zutaten und es ist wirklich mal
versucht werden den asphalt sehr dass
nach machen wollt geht auf meinem blog
cellestis blog.de das stets noch mal für
euch und ich glaube der moral gibt es
erstmals ohne spaß hier das ist so
gigantisch sie so lecker alles so lecker
und er ein tolles ding 14 nachricht und
er ein richtig auf die hose machen
optisch also viel spaß beim nachmachen
bis zum nächsten mal habe ich einiges
gut vorbereiten kann
genau könne auch im tagbau am tag vorher
verbreiten
jetzt noch mal machen als als das
herzhaftes macht es auch wenig ist so
genial was mich aber schon
ja es wird die kleine portion reichtum
für eine person für eine grenze fahren
die x
und
aber es ist mit sicherheit nicht gesund
aber und auch ich halt nicht genau
und übrigens dieses video wurde gesperrt
die sponsoren von der zahnärztekammer in
reutlingen und vielleicht vom adipositas
zentrums